this is the time of year we start
thinking about taxes and today we have
with us author and long-term care
specialist susan marshall the sponsor of
this segment she has a way of putting
money in your pocket and keeping it
there susan welcome back your book
protecting your future with tax-free
income for long-term care
it's so
relevant to our viewers tell us a little
bit about it
it is relevant taxes
can have a huge impact on your financial
future and the book serves to educate
and help get those questions answered
the probably the top financial concern
people have is
how to pay for those long-term care
expenses without going broke well how
big
a problem is long-term care
unfortunately it's bigger than most
people realize consider this we have 8
900 baby boomers turning 65
every day and as they age the need for
care increases alzheimer's
every 65 seconds someone is being
diagnosed with alzheimer's disease and
now
covet is further compound the problem
yeah let's talk about covet a little bit
how much of an impact did that have on
long-term care
sadly since covid we have seen an
increase in the
claims and the need for long-term care
services
but one thing that's interesting is
younger people are now stepping forward
to put a plan in place
i guess they realize it's more than just
nursing home care they it's actually
when you ask people they say
i'd really rather receive this type of
care at home and it the personal care is
those activities of daily living help
with eating dressing bathing things that
you may need help with due to an illness
or an accident well and as someone who's
to go through this with a family member
i experienced this firsthand and it's
very expensive it's not something that
you
expect to have to pay for so
it's very expensive and this really
helps a lot it's good information what
should people plan for well absolutely
you're right that it is extremely
expensive and i think they're caught off
guard because it's considered personal
care so your health plan
and medicare don't cover it because it's
not considered medical it's considered
personal
on top of that this type of care can
cost four to eight thousand dollars a
month or more
and over three and four years it can
easily add up to well over two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars it can get
expensive thank you to susan d marshall
for sponsoring this segment call
702-546-8825
care to the next 100 callers to call the
number on your screen